a republican official has been banned
from Twitter after suggesting that Joe
Biden the President should be killed yes
this is where we are folks it's 2023 and
unfortunately this is where we are and
we've got to deal with it the news Times
reports Brookfield Republican first
select Monterra car kicked off Twitter
after post targeting President Biden now
we actually have the post and we're
going to put it up on the screen for you
there was a uh video here
um of tweeted by the RNC research
account
which was a video of Kamala Harris
saying we have a lot to be thankful for
in Joe Biden and tarakar the elected
official responded to it by saying he
meaning Joe Biden he's aiding and
abetting the enemy Ready Aim Fire one
shot one kill that simple there is not a
lot of nuance there there is not a lot
of nuance there that is a call to shoot
dead the president of the United States
from a republican official as I
mentioned she's been kicked off Twitter
oh Twitter has a liberal bias oh
something just fell off my microphone
that was weird Twitter has a liberal
bias Twitter has because they they said
oh now all of a sudden you get kicked
off for calling for the assassination of
the president what won't they allow next
these folks are genuinely dangerous not
because tarakar herself is likely to go
and kill Joe Biden but because an
environment in which is even remotely
acceptable to say these things if
particularly forget as an average person
but as an as a republican official to
say something like this anything short
of complete denouncement disavow and if
it's on a social media platform Banning
the person
um could be seen as some kind of an
endorsement or approval of it a
republican Town committee chair George
Blass defended the post saying that Carr
was saying shoot the balloon shoot the
balloon not Joe Biden and that it was
taken out of context
um
it genuinely doesn't appear at all that
that is what
um she is arguing for
so there it is another insane action by
these dangerous right-wingers